after you finish a souls game you have
questions
why am i on fire what's the point of
locking myself in this cave
which ending is the right one and of
course the age-old question
and why do they call him big hat logan
first
let's start with the player character
who is the chosen undead
well they are who you make them whether
you were a thief or a knight
from astora or katarina it doesn't
matter
what's important is that you ended up in
a cell at the right place
and the right time for you head to
lordran in accordance with an old legend
that speaks of a mission
for a chosen undead hero this legend is
by the way most likely a deception by
the gods
probably designed to lure powerful
heroes to lordran
but we'll get to that later is there a
world outside lordran
lordran is just the land of the gods and
there is a wider world of man with many
more countries therein
the fate of the world largely revolves
around lordran though
so we never go to these other places but
the characters we do meet in lordran
often hail from these foreign countries
and you can tell that they've been
designed to be accurate
characterizations of their homelands
what you're seeing on screen are the
results of an art competition
to depict these foreign places so check
out that video if you're interested and
subscribe to see the next competition
really soon how did this world come to
be originally
the world had no disparity everything
was just
rock from the land to the trees to the
dragons
it was homogeneous static without
beginning
or end then similar to the big bang fire
suddenly came to exist
and it disrupted this eternal monotony
now there wasn't just
existence but there were states of
existence heat and cold
light and dark life and death the result
was a rock universe gradually changing
into the world as you see it in game
including its overabundance of souls
what is the soul
so when fire came to be and permeated
the universe
so did souls thus the soul is the power
of disparity itself
they are the means by which the first
flame changed the universe and
paradoxically they are both the fuel and
the byproduct
of that fire similar to in demon souls a
soul gives you clarity allowing you to
think
but also life allowing you to be and
just as there are all kinds of life
there are all kinds of souls
of various shapes sizes and magical
affinities
many bosses are these special beings
with special souls and
the most powerful beings are the lords
bearing
lord souls who are the lords and what is
a lord's soul
the four lords are the first kings they
were all
attracted to the first flame having only
ever known darkness before coming upon
it
each one discovered this massive
concentration of disparities power
near the flame which they then used to
establish a kingdom
under their rule thus these massive
souls are called lord souls
of these four souls kath tells us that
the pygmy
found the dark soul and it follows that
the other lord's souls
all aligned with the other aspects of
disparity
so in contrast gwyn found the light soul
nito
found the death soul and the witch of
izalith found the life soul
these souls came to define them and
they would soon ally together to
challenge the everlasting dragons
what is an everlasting dragon so they're
a part of the original race of dragons
that predate life
itself much like there are wyverns and
worms
there are also ancient dragons or arch
dragons as later games coin it
their race is the progenitor to all
other dragon's subspecies
and these are subspecies that adapted
really well to a new world and
new environments you still face some
arch dragons in game
but these arch dragons never are the
original generation of arch dragons that
actually predate fire
the ancient dragons are commonly
described as everlasting
thanks to their stone scales of undeath
granting them immortality
however when gwyn learned that his bolts
of lightning could peel apart
those scales the lords used their full
might to hunt down the archdragons to
nigh extinction ushering in the age of
fire
what is the age of fire it's the era you
find yourself in
it was sparked when the lords defeated
the archdragons
and even as far back as them finding
their lord's souls
could be denoted as the dawn or
beginning of the age of fire
so what follows is this period dominated
by the lords
much of this epoch is also denoted as
the age of gods
since the three lords residing in
lordran with their fellow deities are
on the rise or at their zenith during it
however this golden age can only
continue so long as
fire at the source of the god's power
remains strong
but eventually fire will fade and only
darkness will remain
this quote is what kath describes as
the logic of the world and when that
happens the gods are supposed to be
replaced and their age of fire is
supposed to become an age of dark in the
original dark souls
you find yourself at this crossroad the
first flame is about to go out
even now its power is barely reaching
the world of man
and what follows is a proverbial night
and in this twilight era the undead
curse runs rampant
okay so what is the undead curse ever
since the first flame began to wane
a dark ring of fire has manifested upon
the bodies of certain humans
a sign of the dark burgeoning within
them this dark sign
marks you as an ageless immortal though
your endless revival comes at the cost
of your own souls
and sanity until you eventually hollow
what
caused the undead curse this question is
at the very heart
of this series and the answer is really
quite complex
you'll have a better time with this
though if you're familiar with all three
games
so when the world first began a creature
called the pygmy
found the dark soul who they were isn't
known
nor is it really important what is
important is that they split the dark
soul into fragments
and these fragments came to be known as
humanity
which is a small black spirit found
within every human kath refers to the
furtive pygmy as
your ancestor thus we are descended from
one of the four
lords these games frequently question
whether the dark force within humans
is a positive or a negative thing your
adventure through ullasil in the
artorius of the abyss dlc
is a great example of that here the
darkness within man has gone wild
it's endlessly consuming and corrupting
the land and the souls of people around
it
and yet there is dialogue here that's
supposed to give you pause
i still think on that creature from the
abyss that preyed upon me
my faculties were far from lucid but i
quite
clearly sensed certain emotions a
wrenching nostalgia
lost joy an object of obsession
and a sincere hope to reclaim it could
these thoughts belong to the beast from
the abyss
but if that were true then perhaps it is
no beast after all
this same duality is seen in the
descriptions of dark magic which
are spells that are often driven by
powerful emotions
positive things like love and calm or
negative things like hate
and envy but whether it's positive or
negative gwyn's pantheon
fears the dark for one day as we
mentioned earlier
their age of fire is going to end and
only dark will remain
this was the logic of the world until
gwyn committed the first sin and he
shackled the darkness within man
this was a revelation we received in the
ringed city dlc
where the seal of fire around darkness
on the dark side was finally explicitly
stated to be
a creation of the gods so for some
like manus in the first dlc repression
of their humanity
causes it to writhe and go mad however
this seal of fire was placed upon
mankind so early in their existence
that for most people their shackles are
all that they know
as a result and this is really important
humankind end up living their lives
through
souls that they hold completely separate
from the humanity that's within them you
only have to look
to the white souls of adventurers that
you find in game
as proof of that living like this is the
lie
that aldia talked about in dark souls 2.
all men trust fully the illusion of life
but is this so wrong a construction of
assad and yet
a world and the scandalous
now hello are you intentionally
shattering you
spoiling this wonderful falsehood but in
retrospect
the most chilling dialogue aldia has was
this
once the lord of light had banished dark
and all that stemmed from humanity
and men assumed the freedom for
we're led to believe that the dark sign
cursed humanity with undeath
but aldia's dialogue means this can't be
true
instead aldia says mankind's lives
became
fleeting when they were branded with the
dark side so this means that they were
originally immortals and indeed this is
the state that you return to
when you hollow what is hollowing
humanity once stood proud within every
human
but when the curse was put upon them
humanity became bound
lost and repressed so during this age of
fire humanity came to rely heavily
on their white soul for their sense of
self and we can see this in the names of
these souls
when fire fades the seal of fire
restraining the dark grows weaker
thus when fire fades it follows that our
dark soul
starts to break free consuming the white
soul
that we've come to believe is the self
and
this process of losing the self is
called hollowing
dying or losing heart it accelerates
this process
so an undead must maintain physical and
mental fortitude in order to resist
this process however as you might
remember the hollows of londor in dark
souls 3
believe that their hollow states are
really the most honest
shape of man this isn't an easy truth to
face
especially since the dark soul has
become this ravenous repressed thing to
stay sane as a hollow
one may need to drain the life of others
and the hollows of londor are
universally reviled
as a result of this ultimately it just
leaves you wondering whether
this is really the best path for mankind
or whether it's better to just
accept the shackles of the gods or
whether humanity's fate has been
stolen by the curse either way how do we
cure
the undead curse well curse is an actual
affliction
just like poison or toxin you can
experience its buildup in game
and what this curse does is it locks the
dark soul
away from the self it's really about the
barrier
it's about the separation and the dark
sigil explains this
it says that as humanity leaks out the
curse
accumulates in exchange unfortunately
humans are helpless against curses and
all we can do is redirect their
influence for example
when you use a purging stone what you're
doing is not actually
curing the curse you're actually just
transferring the curse
to this stone and this stone was
or is another person in the original
dark souls we do something similar to
this process
called reverse hollowing so this is a
process that requires you to have
humanity and it's easy to assume that
we're just absorbing the humanity
and restoring our humanity but what's
actually happening here is kind of the
opposite
yes a humanity sprite is taken into the
self
but it then acts as a sort of surrogate
for the curse
like a purging stone does and remember
we offer this humanity up to the bonfire
this keeps our white regular soul safe
and it prevents us from going hollow
further proof of this dynamic exists in
dark souls 2
where using a human effigy is just like
transferring your curse to a human
surrogate and in dark souls 3
we found the purging monument which is
this enormous vessel that's
overflowing with offered curses why did
the gods curse humanity so the logic of
the world denotes that fire will fade
and
only dark will remain naturally gwyn
feared this
and managed to enforce a fleeting form
upon humanity
the fate of mankind became irreversibly
linked to fire
and thus the logic of the world was
changed forever
what is the fire linking it's a ritual
for preserving the first flame
with the decline of fire and the rise of
the dark
and undeath the gods were thrown into
disarray
and the lord's peaceful relations
ultimately collapsed
before things broke down however they
concocted a plan to revive the first
flame with a powerful soul
cultivated through fire keepers and
undead bonfires
this soul would link itself to the fire
and the fire
would inherit a new fuel so gwyn was the
first to link the fire
and many others have taken up that role
since then
what is a bonfire it's your safe haven
undead bonfires are fueled by the bones
of your own kind
and they're connected to the first flame
as a part of a network
through coiled swords the heat that
their flames produce
heal our injuries and can be collected
in a liquid form
called estus as for warping light is
tied to time in this series so
you can reason that a bonfire's light
allows you to warp across
time and space to other bonfires in the
network
bonfires and their fire keepers promote
undead reliance upon fire
and they promote fire's reliance upon
undead thus
the gods are almost certainly behind
their creation
as for who went out and placed them in
the world it's hard to say but it seems
like they can be placed anywhere
where there are undead bones since we
create one ourselves in filing shrine
and even in early versions of the game
you were supposed to be able to place
them yourself
however it's important to remember that
bonfires are primarily
a checkpoint mechanic and gameplay can't
always be explained away by law
for example you might think that all
undead respawn
at the bonfire just like you do but they
don't
according to the crestfallen merchant
what actually happens
is that undead will lay dead for a while
and then later rise where they fell
what is a fire keeper they're a woman
who acts as the living incarnation of a
bonfire in order to preserve its flame
so long as the fire keeper lives so too
does her corresponding bonfire and
vice versa these women are thus vessels
for the countless humanity that is
offered to the bonfire
which means that they receive the dark
spirits along with the effects of the
curse
in the transfer the humanity wriggles
beneath their skin
nipping at body and soul and this causes
great pain and horrific scarring
though not at extremities like the head
or the hands
fire keepers bear this suffering so that
you can benefit from the bonfire
and it's through them and by extension
the bonfires
that you can strengthen your soul with
whatever traits you desire
so be sure to always thank your [ __ ]
your [ __ ]
[Music]
what is wrong with you what is a god
well
they're really whatever humans believe a
deity to be
in most cases the gods refers to members
of gwyn's pantheon
since they're the most widely worshipped
in the world of man
but even those cast out like gwyn's
firstborn are still called a war god
simply because some people still worship
them as such
however just being worshipped doesn't
mean that you have power
an example of this is faris who humans
retroactively deified as the goddess of
the hunt
evlana in dark souls 2. she was just a
heroic bow woman
but her story got twisted over the years
until she became a god
people get kind of hung up on the god
term because
they're trying to define the race of
beings that carry
power in the series for most of these
characters
i quite like the term medial which is a
term proposed by loki what are medials
well many of the god's followers and
descendants aren't human
gods or giants so we kind of have to
make up a term
for these beings medials is good in
terms of size they're often between
humans and giants and these are beings
like the daughters of izalith
or priscilla and so on what are the dead
the dead are corpses
that decay without the power of life
sustaining them however
some like skeletons are often a product
of necromancy and
there's evidence that others like the
ghosts of new londo
become warped by the strong lingering
emotions
of the deceased what is a demon anything
that can be loosely classified as
a monster is called a demon really in
most cases though
demons refers to chaos demons who were
born of the flame of chaos
but there are also titanite demons and
dark souls 2 introduces covetous and
smell to demons as well as a demon of
song it's a common argument
that a demon in dark souls is a chimeric
creature bearing the traits of multiple
animals but
this isn't a given what could be called
crow demons are actually called crow men
or corvians
there are also snake men maggot men and
lion men
all of whom are never called demons like
with
gods the term is somewhat arbitrary
basically a demon is whatever humans
would consider to be
a monster what is chaos chaos
is the nature of fire and life life
is rooted in the soul the soul is a
product of fire's disparity
therefore life like disparity is chaotic
the witch of izalith found the lord's
soul that represents this
and she tried creating her own fire of
life to match that of the first flame
unfortunately this sparked a flame of
chaos
which creates and transforms new often
grotesque
forms of life these became known as the
chaos demons and
they threatened gwyn's rule so you'll
notice that
they're stamped out at every turn in all
chapters of this series the witch of
izalith's
yearning for flame became the basis for
pyromancy
and pyromancy is one of her strongest
surviving legacies
what is pyromancy pyromancy is a
physical form of magic
pyromancers carry along with them a
piece of flame that's
passed down from teacher to student
stretching all the way back to the witch
and her daughters deriving the art from
chaos
and sharing that with the humans
pyromancers then use that flame to
conjure their spells
and despite the name pyromancy isn't
actually limited to
casting fire and it can actually conjure
all kinds of elements
like iron or poison but these are rarer
arts
since pyromancy is a religion that
reveres flame
just so you can manifest pyromancies
like miracles
with your faith or actually even learn
to perform them
like sorceries with your intelligence
what
is sorcery it's a mental form of magic
sorcerers study the natural laws of the
world to
actually comprehend what they are and
how they function
they then use this knowledge to
manipulate their power and
formulate the process as spells which we
call sorcery
they're basically magic scientists and
academics and
there are sorceries from anything from
souls to light
to the dark of the abyss what are
miracles
they're a spiritual form of magic you
cast miracles by reciting legendary
stories
which either feature the spell in
question or
embody what the miracle manifests most
miracles
are thereby based on the power of the
anor londo gods but
there are also dark miracles and hexes
that
achieve similar results your faith in
the story's truth
makes it a reality what is the abyss
it's the power of the dark
and whether that's a pitch-black void
like the realm of the four kings
a viscous dark swamp like in the ringed
city or
a malformed pus like the creatures of
lothric the abyss
can manifest from any humanity and it
produces new life or
twists old life into new forms the abyss
is commonly unstable
and like with manus in all a seal it can
go wild
devouring and corrupting the souls of
every other form of life but it was not
always this way
the gods placed a curse upon the abyss
and
while humans have largely lost
connection with it
there are multiple sources that suggest
the abyss can offer great comfort to
humankind
however it appears that path was lost
when the abyss was banished and
now it simply hungers what is black
flame
black flame is the impenetrable fire of
humanity
inspired by the power of our quote
unquote
untouchable soul in kind of a similar
way to how pyromancy is
inspired by izalith's soul what is the
deep
as the age of dark continues to be
delayed some dark
stagnates into the deep and here the
weight of humanity sinks
into a horrific abyss like a deep sea
where no light reaches many worship the
concept of the deep
as these dregs are seen as the bedrock
of the world
and you can almost view the deep as a
sort of abyssal religion
its leader aldridge concluded that if
the world continued to darken
then there would eventually be an age of
the deep sea
why is time convoluted with the first
flame waning
the power of light also fades and since
light is related to time the flow of
time has stagnated in a land where the
flame is located
due to this instability time spaces
known as
other worlds can randomly intersect here
and this allows you to briefly
meet people from long before your
timeline and with the help of
magic you can cross the gaps between
worlds usually as spirits
why is everything in the world hostile
to me after watching this video you'll
enjoy
my video talking about all the bosses of
dark souls 3
if you've played it i'll just list a
bunch of reasons on screen though
because every enemy does have a reason
for attacking you after all
except priscilla i mean why did you hurt
her that's
actually really [ __ ] up what is the
painted world the first painting we're
introduced to
is the painted world of ariamis which is
hung
in an orlando it was a place to hide all
the things that the gods feared
and so it's filled with many references
to sin
and the occult in the ashes of aryandel
dlc
we learn that the paintings are a mirror
of the outside world
and so are burned and reborn to mimic
the linking of the fire
just so there are those on the inside
who would prefer
to let the painting rot what is the
meaning of each ending
so in dark souls you're presented with
two choices after you defeat
the lord of cinder either you inherit
the fire and join the line of succession
preserving the current world order or
you leave the fire to die
without fuel allowing the universe to
reach its natural conclusion
by becoming a lord of cinder you
sacrifice yourself to restore the light
by becoming a dark lord you choose to
lead mankind into a new
dark age with an uncertain future in
dark souls 2
fire still wanes while the curse still
flourishes
you assume a throne inside of a kiln
which
takes you to the first flame and the
lord of cinder
where you'll make one of these two
choices turns out neither of them
really matter for the world will
continue to ebb and flow
between light and dark so maybe you
should heed
a certain scholars proposition instead a
new ending here
is to neither rekindle nor squelch
the first flame just simply embrace this
twilight era and
see what it has in store as if to follow
the consequences of this choice
dark souls 3 shows you a world where the
future lords of cinder refuse
to either save the age of fire or usher
in an age of dark
and in the tumult that followed you are
again
presented with a choice do you continue
to link the fire
despite the ritual not being as
impactful
as before do you use the dark of the
curse to
subsume the flame and lead the undead
into a new age as their lord of hollows
do you let your fire keeper snuff out
the fire and herald in the darkness
only to learn that embers survive
amongst the countless lords who linked
the flame before
you or do you betray her and take what
fire remains
all for yourself you are unkindled ash
after all what is unkindled ash these
are undead who previously tried and
failed
to link the fire you weren't strong
enough to bear the flame that you
inherited
but you weren't weak enough to stay
reduced to ash
either and so you became ash devoid of
flame
but still requiring embers as well as
souls
to heat your cold cursed frame hence
unkindled are destined to seek the fire
that remains in the world
how does the series end well it ends
with ash
literally as the world burns out again
and again
ash itself arises this is a new being
a new species really that's composed of
a thousand failures
who had tried to link the fire over the
years
but ash doesn't really belong in this
world
and honestly they have more in common
with the beings of the painted world
instead
where all of fire's discarded things
reside
so they fight for a new purpose to
reunite the dark soul
and paint a new world with it so that we
can finally
escape this ashen wasteland that gwyn
has created
so a slave knight called gale hollowed
beyond belief
sacrifices himself for a new world and
the painter
paints a world called ash a cold
dark and very gentle place
this video is too broad i want specifics
join the club
subscribe check out other creators in
this space
and enjoy endless hours of content that
has been made in the years before you
saw this video
before i go i wanted to give a shout out
to one of my favorite twitch streamers
39 daff i watched her watch my videos
after she completed dark souls 3
and you know it really helped me i felt
like i really understood some of the
sorts of questions that people must have
after they watch my videos who's
the chest who is the big
great chat i had her confusion was why i
decided to sign you all up to extra
classes today so
follow her stream and thank her for that
thank you for watching
and i'll see you next time when is elden
ring being released i actually have the
answer to this one
recently i had it leaked to me so i
figured i put it right at the end of the
video while no one else is watching
so just quickly don't tell anyone the
release date of eldon ring is